and after that ribbon-cutting ceremony
this morning the first major convention
since the pandemic will finally get
underway here in las vegas this is so
exciting
world of concrete also the first to use
that expansion space
hector mejia joins us there live now
with a preview hey hector
hey there good morning it's an exciting
day for thousands of people just
standing here and looking at
everyone getting to work and just
walking around it feels like everything
is back to normal and out there we have
the shuttle buses moving around back and
forth bringing people to work and off to
the left
we have part of the world of concrete
there we have people setting things up
last minute setups
local vendors and also exciting day for
those who are
in town waking up in hotel rooms this
morning we have new video from the west
hall as world of concrete got all set up
over the last few days
bringing the latest and greatest in the
construction industry along with nearly
60 thousand people haven't said that in
a while
companies like deep south are showcasing
what they specialize in
in their case it's bridge replacements
down in louisiana
they offer solutions like building
off-site and taking those things
incrementally so that builders don't
have to shut down an
entire interstate at once and cause big
traffic jams
the company says they also make cranes
we're a 50 year old family-owned company
so the same family owns
owns it and operates it we have cranes
up to uh 3 000 ton capacity which is
really some of the largest cranes in the
world but it's really known for a very
small footprint
and uh and it's got a really long
lifting radius
so world of concrete is going on today
through thursday
last year it was scheduled in february
and it did happen because that was
before the pandemic canceled conventions
and back out here live you're looking at
a sign that says welcome
to world of concrete with a really cool
skyline
of the las vegas strip made up of
different construction
tools as you see there and again a
little later this morning that is when
the
ribbon cutting ceremony will take place
let me just show you off to the side
just to show you all the activity going
on
life back here at the las vegas
convention center as a lot of people
get ready to make sure these grounds are
spotless and perfect and ready to go
for the thousands of people that are
crowding our town reporting live hector
mejia
8 news now wow it is so cool to finally
talk about a major convention back in
town hector
thank you so much we'll see in a little
bit